ah
tengo un hermano
y a mi hermano toda la vida le
preguntaban por su trabajo en cambio a
mí por los novios crecí sintiendo que mi
vida emocional era mi carta de
presentación y la de mi hermano pues de
laboral eso hizo que yo estudiara con
más ganas carrera medicina doctorado
tres máster otra licenciatura de
antropología están 100 san diego en
estados unidos y acabo de venir ayer de
ciudad del cabo para profundizar los
marcadores genéticos para el dolor os
puedo asegurar que lo que os voy a
contar hoy aquí os hará olvidar mi
estado civil soy 'fan' atairo médico
investigadora y me encanta desmontar
estereotipos de género que son creencias
de lo que se debe hacer pensar y ser si
eres chico o chica y son tan
contundentes que a la edad de nueve años
y ya están instalado en tu cerebro sin
que te ven muchas más explicaciones
el rosa es de
chicas y el azul es de chicos los chicos
llevan el pelo corto y las chicas
a caras de 15 apunta a kárate chicos y
las chicas son más pues de gimnasia
rítmica
qué os parecería si os dijera que estos
son creencias que forma parte de la
cultura así que vamos a hablar si de
verdad los chicos y las chicas somos tan
diferentes como nos han contado porque
varios un poco de miopía cultural y una
miopía con algunas gafas de la ciencia
igual se puede corregir empecemos por el
principio a una mujer embarazada que es
de lo primero que se le pregunta
el niño o en niña de hecho hay un montón
de creencias y de formas populares para
médicas de saber si es niño o niña la
barriga en punta lávate la cara y si
eras guapa creo que eres ni niño
salvo que te hagas un test genético en
sangre la embriología nos lo va a
desvelar a las 20 semanas de gestación
que es cuando si eres niño descienden el
pene y la bolsa escrotal son palabras
raras pero estamos una charla de ciencia
en cambio si eres niña
se define por ausencia de órganos
masculinos
a usted tiene órganos masculinos que más
desaparecen que teníamos antes la nada
un vacío una ausencia pues pese a lo que
no nos han contado y pese a quien le
pese las mujeres tenemos los mismos
órganos genitales que los hombres
proporcionalmente del mismo tamaño y del
mismo color pero en la mujer como en el
embrión se guardan dentro de hecho
nuestra máxima diferencia en genitalidad
es entre hombres y mujeres se podría
explicar en un programa de barrio sésamo
con epi blas arriba chica abajo tipo
dentro
chico y ya está en los hombres o en los
efectos masculinos en su clítoris
también llamado pene desciende junto a
los ovarios también llamados testículos
y su bolsa escrotal también llamada
vulva
ya sé que esta vez queda con cara de
consternación nadie se lo ha contado
antes vamos más sencillo los niños
tienen pene y las niñas
y hoy
hoy voy a repetirlo los niños tienen
pene y las niñas tienen clítoris
las mujeres tienen vulva y los hombres
tienen
vulva
pero se llama escroto y además está
cerrado a modo de cremallera por una
cicatriz que tenéis todos y se llama
rafa que es esta cicatriz
es vuestra vulva con vuestro orificio
vaginal cerrado
ya sé que esto es muy sorprendente hay
unas clases con espejitos para analizar
la genitalidad os lo aconsejo
las mujeres tienen próstata
los hombros también pero las mujeres nos
cambió el nombre se llama glándulas de
skene que es un ginecólogo escocés que
la encontró que lo encontró hace dos
siglos
seréis consternados no sé por qué si la
naturaleza es muy diversa por ejemplo en
ciudad del cabo que acaba de venir si
hace mucho calor por ejemplo los
elefantes
se guardan los testículos dentro no los
descienden no hace calor mejor dentro en
cambio las mamíferas hembras llenas
desciende en su clítoris
y claro os recuerdo son del mismo tamaño
del mismo color entonces no han llamado
pseudo pene
falso por si acaso pseudo pene falso y
digo tanto cuesta pronunciar la palabra
clítoris si rufo de éfeso levantara la
cabeza que se lo encontró en el siglo 2
después de cristo pero claro nadie le
hizo caso ni a él ni a karen hornet
green hornet fue una psicoanalista del
siglo pasado que rebatió con dureza
ciertas teorías de freud como la envidia
del pene si hubiera sido de este siglo
me hubieran llamado la rosalía el
psicoanálisis porque decía muy mal muy
mal
freud malamente
ella decía como que la media del pene lo
que lo que nosotros enviamos es la
libertad que tiene el hombre por tener
un pene
esta idea sigue en nuestros cerebros y
eso que hay otras tecnologías anatómicas
que nos parecen más normales por ejemplo
cómo se llama abrazo en los chicos brazo
como se llama pulmón en las chicas
pulmón como se llama
esternocleidomastoideo occipucio que es
una palabra muy rara pero que está aquí
se llama todo igual pero hay cuando
llegamos a los países bajos
todo tiene que cambiar porque tiene que
estar muy claro por ejemplo si te
llamabas maga y wii con un pene no
descendido pues no podías estar no te
podían contactar en la universidad de
cracovia que tenían que mandar a un
laboratorio con goteras
estas concepciones estas creencias yo os
quiero demostrar que tienen muy poca
base biológica que son como las primeras
fake nus de la genitalidad
pero pero claro la sociedad se empeña en
meternos en esa dualidad y en esa
separación y yo yo yo yo yo pensaba
mucho digo
y que que nos puede separar no que nos
puede diferenciar así potente entre
hombres y mujeres y dio la genitalidad
no es pues no sé qué será
las hormonas pero ya estas son las
hormonas no la testosterona y los
estrógenos pues queridos y queridas otra
fake newbery very very golf
la testosterona y los estrógenos son
casi idénticos les separan un puente de
hidrógeno y yo digo y ese puente de
hidrógeno puede soportar el techo de
cristal la conciliación laboral la
brecha salarial y nuestra inspiración
histórica también en ciencia puede con
todo eso
yo creo que no de verdad el cambio
en cambio
sí que puede matizar cómo metaboliza mos
los medicamentos los estrógenos influyen
tan claramente en el hígado puede
matizar que expresemos las enfermedades
un poquito diferentes o la diferente
prevalencia de enfermedades entre
hombres y mujeres incluso el cableado
cerebral o la expresión genética
por ejemplo los infartos agudos de
miocardio no los percibimos igual las
mujeres que los hombres los hombres como
es como en las películas de vaqueros no
va al médico y dije tengo una presión
que me baja no sé doctor rival igual me
enamora y el médico le dice no es un
infarto agudo de miocardio cateterismo y
estaré del hospital con un con un bypass
de tres vasos
ay querida pero si eres una mujer
vas al médico y le dices tengo que un
dolor unas náuseas y tengo un cansancio
como que me cuesta hacer las cosas no y
le dice el médico
mucho mucho trabajo en casa estás
nerviosa como algún problema nuevo y lo
más probable es que esa mujer salga de
la consulta con un ansiolítico
con un ansiolítico porque en las
carreras de medicina no se explican que
los hombres y las mujeres manifestamos
las enfermedades de forma diversa
entonces no las diagnosticamos y no las
tratamos igual y las mujeres se mueren
más de infarto agudo de miocardio porque
no lo vemos no lo vemos
de hecho las mujeres tienen un retraso
en sus diagnósticos médicos un retraso
de 5 a 7 años más que los hombres yendo
al médico las mismas veces
5 a 7 años en cambio nos dan 4 veces más
medicamentos antidepresivos y
ansiolíticos como nos comprenden las
enfermedades nos medican el cerebro
es así
por ejemplo sabéis lo que era el viagra
femenino
es masculino si un vasodilatador que
incrementa el flujo sanguíneo al pene
para mantener la erección
sabéis que era el viagra femenino un
antidepresivo y os sorpresa no funcionó
no funcionó dio cuarta miopía de género
típico miopía no esto se llama ceguera
de género y aquí estoy aquí porque a la
ciencia ya la medicina le hace falta
ponerse unas buenas gafas con
perspectivas de género hoy estoy aquí
porque en la carrera no me explicaron
que existía un órgano que se llamaba
clítoris y por tanto ninguna enfermedad
y ningún tratamiento para ninguna
disfunción que pudiera padecer salvo un
antidepresivo hoy estoy aquí porque hace
falta que la ciencia nos dé datos y nos
abra los ojos para construir entre todos
una sanidad más igualitaria
y si a alguien le quedan ganas aún de
saber si tengo pareja novio o mascota
que me arrulló
que se lo pregunte a mi hermano
[Aplausos]